c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Séparons-nous Je Me souvenirs du bord de mer
avec cill cla IL av l'hospitali c'était
pas fait pour nous
déplier tellement qu'ils sont beaux
on pouvait lire dans le prelle qu'elle
je voulais pratiquer le Sport pour regarder
une Belle ligne de corp et Encore et en
j'aurais pu danser la
[Musique]
jit chouette les filles du bord de
[Applaudissements]
mer éta fait pour qui sarit
faire IL en ait une qui s'appelait ave
oui tweet vraiment la fille m rv elle
n'avait qu'un seul défaut elle est se
qu'il me faut
Plus d'aller chez le maur elle l'invite
premier
baigne du cé de son cur en douceur en
[Musique]
douceur en douceur et
profondeur chouette les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les filles
[Musique]
lui par c Je propose de partager ma
Ven Je comm
moi sur la mer
nord faire SP Je to ce viol sinon deven
[Musique]
maling
un beaujour j'en Ai eu marre cé pique la
mer boire jeil ric et j'ai nage vers
d'autres
[Musique]
zta chouette les fill du bord de
mer
pour le une
Italie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la